madame monsieur bonsoir l'actualité de
ce mardi marquée par cette avalanche qui
s'est produite cet après midi dans le
massif du mont blanc
une personne est morte deux autres ont
été blessés les variations de
température explique sans doute cet
accident
lancement réussi repos discovery la
navette spatiales américaines et son
équipage ont retrouvé le chemin de la
station spatiale internationale
une mission à haut risque 2 ans et demi
après la catastrophe de columbia
alexis cet adolescent atteint d'une
leucémie pourra choisir son hôpital le
tribunal d'angers a décidé de rendre
l'autorité parentale à son père et à sa
mère
ils avaient ils avaient perdu leurs
droits après un différend avec un
médecin
la visite en france d'ariel sharon
marque le retour à des relations
apaisées entre les deux pays
on se souvient que l'on passé israël
avait accusé la france d' antisémitisme
sauvage changement de propriétaire au
crazy horse le célèbre cabaret parisien
passe aux mains d'investisseurs belges
mais promis l'esprit des revues sera
respectée
les archéologues n'en finissent pas de
fouiller les vestiges de l'alabama ce
navire américain de la guerre de
sécession repose à 60 mètres de fond au
large de cherbourg
l'avalanche s'est donc produite à plus
de 4000 mètres d'altitude sur la voie
normale du mont blanc la coulée de glace
et de neige et et large de 400 m une
personne est morte deux autres blessés
benoît gadré olivier jacquin c'est une
avalanche de séracs d'une très grande
ampleur aux dires des spécialistes les
séracs ces énormes blocs de glace dont
l'un s'est décroché cet après midi ici
dans la face nord du mont-blanc du tacul
six militaires étrangers formant une
corde et ont été balayés par cette
coulée un alpiniste est mort deux sont
grièvement blessés les autres très
choqué l'avalanche de séracs un
phénomène connu par tous les montagnards
pour son côté aléatoire ça fait partie
du danger objectif que l'on prend en
compte quand on ne s'engage en montagne
je suis de pierre la chute entrave azul
la chute de séracs sait des choses ce
sont des pièges ce sont des choses qui
se produisent couramment vu que mon nom
que l'on s'est rencontré
là où on va gendarmes de haute-montagne
crs maîtres chiens guides des moyens
importants ont été mobilisés
il faut dire que la face nord du
mont-blanc du tacul est l'une des voix
les plus empruntées l'été plusieurs
dizaines d'alpinistes la fréquentent
chaque jour pour atteindre le sommet du
mont blanc au départ de l'aiguillé du
midi
le bilan est lourd mais il aurait pu
être catastrophique si l'avalanche avait
eu lieu au petit matin à l'heure où les
cordes et entament leur ascension vers
le mont blanc oui en direct de chamonix
on retrouve notre envoyé spécial benoît
gadret benoît est on vraiment sûr ce
soir qu'il n'y a plus personne sous
l'avalanche et bien a priori il n'y a
plus personne commandant bonneville
commandant du pghm peloton de
gendarmerie de haute montagne de
chamonix viennent nous indiquer un
instant que les recherches étaient
interrompues tous les secouristes sont
redescendus dans la vallée et a priori
il n'y a plus personne sous cette
avalanche de séracs on peut penser que
les six militaires qui sont a priori
d'origine britannique a priori d'origine
britannique seraient les seules victimes
alors d'importants moyens ont été
déployés vers 15 heures dès l'alerté
donnée une cinquantaine de secouristes
ont été envoyés sur place car comme je
vous l'indiquais cette avalanche d'abord
est très importante
exceptionnel nous a dit le pilote
d'hélicoptère qui nous accompagnait et
puis parce que c'est une voie très très
très empruntée il faut savoir que dans
le massif du mont blanc il ya trois à
quatre cents à zell piste chaque jour
qui fréquentent ce massif et plusieurs
dizaines empruntent cette voie vers le
mont blanc qui prend son départ à
l'aiguillé du midi et qui prend la face
nord en suivant de suite la face nord du
mont-blanc du tacul donc le bilan est
lourd bien sûr un mort deux blessés dont
un grave et il aurait pu être vraiment
catastrophique
merci benoît est bien sûr prudents eux
demain si vous devez vous aventurer dans
ce secteur une météo clémente pas
d'ennuis techniques les scientifiques de
la nasa peuvent souffler ce soir après
un lancement réussi 10
ouvry est en route vers la station
internationale alain de chalvron sans
problème à 16h39 précise la navette
s'est élevée dans le ciel alors que
l'amérique toute entière
laura bush en tête du tout votre
vaisseau
deux minutes après le top départ les
deux fusées d'appoint se sépare de
discovery en salle
on commence à respirer mais on respirera
complètement que six minutes et demie
plus tard lorsque la navette l'arc sans
problème son gros réservoir rouge
ce réservoir plein de deux millions de
litres d'oxygène et d'hydrogène
objet de toutes les angoisses depuis
qu'il ya quinze jours
cette petite pièce à capteur de niveau a
fait capoter le lancement en ne
répondant pas pendant deux semaines la
nasa a cherché à comprendre pourquoi ce
capteur ne fonctionnait pas s'en trouver
le patron de l' agence visiblement
exténué prend alors une décision sans
précédent nous ne nions pas le problème
mais nous avons croisé toutes les
hypothèses je ne pense offert avec en
toute connaissance de cause autrement
dit le lancement aurait bien lieu même
si un des quatre capteurs ne fonctionné
pas risques calculés
calcul réussi michael et fils a changé
de tête
les ingénieurs n'aime pas les expliquer
et maintenant que le lancement effet on
ne saura jamais ce qui s'est passé singh
les sept membres d'équipage avaient le
sourire au moment de prendre position
dans le cockpit
ce risque calculé ils avaient été les
premiers à l'accepter à l'heure qu'il
est ils sont en orbite autour de la
terre
oui les sept astronautes vont rester 12
jours dans l'espace dont neuf arrimé à
la station spatiale internationale
il apporte du ravitaillement et des
pièces de rechange très attendu là-bas
une mission à haut risque 2 ans et demi
après la catastrophe de columbia nicolas
chateauneuf philippe turpault la mission
de discovery c'est de faire oublier ces
images celle de la désintégration de
columbia et de ses sept astronautes
il y a deux ans et demi dans le ciel du
texas depuis les ingénieurs de la nasa
ont tout fait pour permettre aux trois
navettes restantes de re décoller
objectif rendre plus sûre des engins
conçus il ya plus de trente ans les
bords d'attaqué des ailes ont été
renforcées
les joints des boosters aussi le
réservoir central a été amélioré et un
bras articulé a même été rajoutés pour
inspecter d'éventuels dommages car la
lavette a encore beaucoup de travail
elle doit notamment terminé la
construction de la station spatiale
internationale
bloqué à mi chemin on espère faire de
vol cette année et ensuite quatre ou
cinq vols par an jusqu'à ce que la
station spatiale soit complète
cela devrait prendre environ 28 vols la
navette sera alors mise à la retraite et
sera remplacé
on l'espère par le véhicule
d'exploration habitée voici à quoi
ressemblera peut-être l'engin qui
prendra la relève de la navette en 2010
en attendant celle ci devra encore volé
mais toujours sous haute surveillance ce
qui était possible
il y a 6 ans quand discovery réparer le
télescope spatial hubble est aujourd'hui
devenu trop risques et sur la base
aérienne militaire d'istres dans les
bouches-du-rhône
on a suivi avec beaucoup d'attention le
décollage de discovery sur cette base
160 militaires français du personnel
américains étaient mobilisés pour
accueillir la navette en cas de
problèmes techniques au décollage deux
autres bases en espagne avait également
été mobilisé en cas de défaillance
l'actualité judiciaire les parents du
jeune alexis retrouvent leurs droits
parentaux
c'est ce que vient de décider la cour
d'appel d'angers alexis à 15 ans il est
atteint d'un cancer
ses parents avaient été privés de sa
garde pour s'être opposée à une décision
médicale
françois privat à l'intérieur cet après
midi pour alexis tout est allé très vite
une heure à peine pour que la cour
d'appel des mineurs danger l'autorisent
à se faire soigner dans l'hôpital de son
choix
maintenant mon seul objectif ni au samu
un soulagement
il y avait une grande cicatrice en nous
et là quelque part il ya quelques
pansements qui soumit alexis avec une
longue journée devant la justice le
jeune homme est atteint de la maladie de
hodgkin un cancer des ganglions
difficile à soigner
ce matin il a dû une première fois
expliqué pourquoi lui comme ses parents
refusé le traitement préconisé par son
médecin traitant
quand tu es médecins professionnels vous
dis que si tu fais rien tumeur qui fait
le 13 tu plonges ta vie et si le terrain
ça marche pas bien tu mettras des
comprimés pour retourner doucement on
peut avoir confiance en des médecins 12
à fin juin
s'estimant désavoué le médecin traitant
d'alexis saisit alors la justice qui
place le jeune homme au chu d'angers où
l'on souhaitait trouver rapidement une
solution c'est la santé de l'enfant
aventure absolument je crois que c'est
véritablement la seule préoccupation des
équipes médicales du chu l'ange dès ce
soir conformément à ses souhaits alexis
sera accueilli à l'hôpital de bobigny
pour y subir une série d'examens
médicaux avant d'entamer si cela s'avère
nécessaire
un nouveau traitement la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme vient de condamner
la france elle estime que notre
législation ne condamnez pas assez
sévèrement ce que l'on appelle l'
esclavage moderne une jeune togolaise
exploité pendant quatre ans par un
couple de riches parisiens avaient saisi
les juges européens paul de genève anne
sophie chemier le compte aujourd'hui la
vie lui sourit un fils de 4 mois un
mariage un travail des aides soignantes
et surtout la reconnaissance de son
passé des esclaves domestiques car entre
1994 et 1998 un couple l'a employé comme
bonne à tout faire sans aucune
rémunération 18 heures par jour sept
jours sur sept
elle a porté plainte mais ses employeurs
n'ont été condamné qu'à dix mille francs
d'amendé aujourd'hui la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme condamne la france
estimant que cette sanction n'était pas
suffisamment sévères ça va pas réparer
ce que j'ai vécu pendant cinq ans et ne
se passera jamais se passer de ma vie me
suivra toujours longtemps et toute ma
vie mais c'est quand même un pas vers la
je pouvais sauter maintenant sept
passagers et recommencer à un début je
pense les époux bardet avait été
condamné en octobre 2000 par la cour
d'appel de paris à une simple amende une
peine bien trop légère pour six mois
coface
depuis elle n'a eu de cesse de faire
reconnaître sa situation des esclaves
domestiques
aujourd'hui pour son avocate la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme définit
clairement endroit cette notion cet
arrêt me semble important parce qu'ils
posent très bons les bases d'une
jurisprudence internationale sur la
question sa base l'article 4 de la
convention européenne des droits de
l'homme qui interdit de façon absolue
l'esclavagé la servitude ou le travail
forcé ou obligatoire
la france n'a pas attendu cette
condamnation pour changer sa loi depuis
2003 les textes ne sont plus sévères le
gouvernement français pourrait demander
un réexamen de cette décision pour le
faire reconnaît en corse la police et la
gendarmerie recherchent toujours le
commando qui a attaqué hier un fourgon
blindé de transport de fonds
les six braqueurs ont pu s'enfuir avec
un butin évalué à un million d'euros
a priori un travail de professionnel
romain clément
les malfaiteurs n'ont laissé derrière
eux que cette carcasse calcinée une
camionnette dont ils se sont servis pour
dérober à l'intérieur de ce fourgon
blindé
la somme d'un million d'euros
hier sur cette route la seule reliant
folelli à moriani le fourgon de la
société s retourne vers bastia les
coffres sont pleins les convoyeurs
viennent de terminer leur tournée
c'est à ce moment précis que le commando
entre en action deux camionnettes se
place en travers de la route
les six hommes menacent les convoyeurs
avec un lance-roquettes et s'empare du
butin dont plusieurs sacs sont sans
protection particulière pour laisser le
moins de traces possibles ils incendient
les deux véhicules puis s'enfuit à bord
d'une autre voiture
on est frappé par le professionnalisme
de l'équipe qui a agi qui paraît avoir
particulièrement bien préparé son action
en corse il n'y avait pas eu d'attaqué
contre des convoyeurs depuis deux ans le
butin est exceptionnel le mode
opératoire aussi
d'autant que la société de transport est
connu pour ses liens avec les
nationalistes
trois britanniques ont été placés en
garde à vue la police a découvert hier
kilos de cocaïne dans l'acquis de leur
voilier qui était amarré dans le port de
saint mandrier dans le var valeur
marchande d'environ 6 millions d'euros
c'est un renseignement anonyme qui a
permis d'effectuer cette saisie et puis
méthodes plus classiques mais saisit
très importante près de biarritz près de
quatre tonnes de cannabis ont été
découvertes à bord d'un camion
immatriculé aux pays-bas
il s'agit de la deuxième plus grosse
saisie cette année pour ce type de
drogue
anouk burel philippe dumas il fallait
avoir l'oeil trouver la cache dans la
remorque derrière les bâches les cuves
de plastique sous ses cuves un double
fond le trafic était bien voter dans la
zone du cannabis par valises entières
on les appelle des valises marocaines le
chauffeur hollandais en transportait
plus de trois tonnes 7 des milliers de
petites plaquettes découper emballé déjà
prêtes à la vente
la forme de base au secteur général est
très souvent la plaquette que la
plaquette de 250 grammes nous avons
aussi le format tablette de chocolat qui
est un petit peu plus léger à l'unité si
mes souvenirs sont exacts il s'agit de
la deuxième saisie par ordre
d'importance
réalisé par les douaniers français en
2005 valeur marchande 7 millions quatre
cent mille euros
une saisie exceptionnelle le chauffeur
transiter entre l'espagne et la hollande
un axe majeur du trafic de cannabis en
europe son comportement l'a trahi
quelques documents aussi et a toujours
les erreurs que pour mettre les
transporteurs une organisation de fraude
qui sont pas toujours faciles à déceler
à l'examen on s'est rendu compte que la
carte grise alors alors que ne
correspondait pas à l'immatriculation
d'armand on s'est quand même
ces reçus depuis le début de l'année 8
tonne et demie de cannabis 3 comme 4
d'ecstasy 72 kg d'héroïne et de cocaïne
ont été saisis le quotidien peu
ordinaire des contrôleurs des douanes
sur ce grand carrefour des trafics de
l'europe cette image spectaculaire de ce
violent incendie qui s'est déclaré vers
midi dans un entrepôt d'aubervilliers en
seine saint denis
le feu a détruit une partie d'un
entrepôt de 6 mètres carrés de stockage
de dormez alimentaire 300 personnes
vivant autour du site ont dû être
évacuées il n'y a eu aucun blessé et le
feu est maintenant éteint après les
attentats de londres de sharm al shaer
jacques chirac a présidé aujourd'hui à
conseil de sécurité intérieure le chef
de l'état a confirmé le niveau rouge du
plan vigipirate
un projet de loi sera prêt d'ici fin
août ils concernent notamment le
renforcement de la vidéosurveillance un
moyen déjà très utilisé en grande
bretagne christophe widemann hervé pozzo
des images de vidéosurveillance qui ont
fait le tour du monde
les kamikazes du 7 juillet les poseurs
de bombes du 21
filmé dans les transports londoniens
c'est preuve par l'image ne doivent rien
au hasard
en grande bretagne les caméras sont
partout 3 à 4 millions dans l'espace
public
rien que dans la capitale il y en a 150
milles contre moins de 20000 à paris
cette salle de contrôle de la préfecture
de police parisienne est relié à trois
mille caméras
lorsqu'on a un fait
graver un délit ou un crime qu'ils aient
commis lorsque la vidéo est présente ça
nous permet de d'extraire les images
utile et d'identifier les auteurs
beaucoup plus vite effectivement encore
faut-il que les images soient
enregistrés ce qui n'est pas le cas pour
deux tiers de ces caméras
nous avons des outils qui sont mises en
place et des caméras dans la capitale il
ya des caméras dans toutes les grandes
villes et qui ne servent en gros à rien
dans le cadre de la lutte antiterroriste
le gouvernement veut intensifier la
vidéo surveillance généralisée
l'enregistrement faciliter l'accès aux
images pour la police et surtout
multiplier le nombre de caméras 500
supplémentaires dans les rues
parisiennes et près de 10000 dans les
transports publics
un projet de loi doit être bouclé d'ici
fin août
en grande bretagne il enquête sur les
attentats manqués de jeudi dernier s'est
concentré aujourd'hui autour d'un
appartement au nord de londres
la police pense qu'il a servi de repère
à deux des quatre terroristes
les perquisitions sur place pourrait
bien apporter de nouveaux indices
jacques cardoze paulo puis mental cette
fois il approche du but
les enquêteurs de scotland yard ont
découvert l'appartement de deux des
quatre suspects des derniers attentats
mokhtar ibrahim 27 ans britannique
d'origine érythréenne et yassim omar 24
ans somaliens vivent est au neuvième
étage de cet hlm depuis 1999
deux autres personnes les avait rejoint
dernièrement la police annonce avoir
trouvé un matériel intéressant parce
qu'il correspond aux indices laissés par
les poseurs de bombes
ce que confirme ses voisins rencontrés
aujourd'hui qu'ils se souviennent
d'avoir vu une cinquantaine de boîtes en
plastique
il y a trois semaines il y a trois ou
quatre semaines je les ai vu rentrer
chez eux avec beaucoup de bois vous leur
avez parlé et qu'est ce que vous leur
avez demandé
je lui ai demandé ce qui est trois
orteils il a dit que c'était du produit
pour décoller son papier peint parce
qu'il redécoré
te ment comme beaucoup dans le quartier
sami jones a été interrogé par la police
son fils jouait au football fréquemment
avec moctar ibrahim selon les médias
britanniques citant des services de
police des explosifs auraient été
retrouvés juste en face dans ce garage
celui ci a été inspectée toute la
journée par les spécialistes de
l'identification
l'enquète a connu une avancée importante
ce soir avec la découverte de cet
appartement même si les quatre auteurs
présumés des attentats de jeudi dernier
sont toujours en fuite
dans le cadre de la coopération
antiterroriste entre la france et
l'espagne deux hommes ont été
interpellés ce matin près de l'île à la
frontière belge
il s'agit d'un homme d'origine marocaine
et de son fils placé en garde à vue ils
sont entendus sur le dossier des
attentats de madrid en mars 2004
et puis en egypte les forces de sécurité
continuent à mener des opérations dans
le sud du sinaï pour tenter de retrouver
les auteurs des attentats de sharm el
cheikh aujourd'hui les autorités
égyptiennes ne sont plus aussi
affirmatif sur la piste pakistanaise
en tout cas dont toutes les gîtes il
existe un terreau favorable aux
islamistes
nos envoyés spéciaux au caire yann fanti
à la location ont pu constater que tous
les milieux sociaux sont concernés à
l'image du caire qui rogne sur le désert
les associations islamistes sont comme
ces immeubles en construction
chaque jour elle gagne un peu plus de
terrain en egypte
illustration avec ce centre installé
dans ce nouveau quartier
ici on aide les plus pauvres
distribution de vêtements ou encore de
médicaments les familles démunies
viennent chercher de quoi subvenir à
leurs besoins
je ne peux pas me faire soigner vous
savez moi j'ai de gros problèmes de
santé j'ai mal au foie mais je n'ai pas
les moyens d'aller à l'hôpital
heureusement qu'elles sont là ces
mouvements religieux s'engouffre partout
là où le gouvernement a baissé les bras
faute de moyens ou de réelle volonté
politique dans ce centre par exemple il
ya même un orphelinat avec 40 bbc
associations profitent des failles du
système pour répondre leurs idées
évidemment on fait ce que le
gouvernement ne fait pas mais en même
temps il ne peut pas être présent
partout et puis vous savez nos activités
sont égales aux motards dans un pays où
deux tiers de la population vit avec
moins d'un euro par jour
ces mouvements trouve de plus en plus
d'échos revues dvd sont en vente libre
signe évident de leur succès le nombre
de femmes voilées
jusqu'à maintenant ils touchaient les
couches populaires
ils recrutent aussi désormais dans les
classes aisées par le biais de la
télévision satellite
khaled est l'une des stars du moment ce
prédicateur religieux aux costumes bien
coupés véhicule une vision rigoriste de
l'islam sous couvert de modernité
interdit voire durement réprimée ces
mouvements à leurs adeptes n'hésitent
plus à manifester dans la rue comme ici
au caire il ya quelques jours elle donne
à l'image qu'ils sont moins corrompus
que les autres aussi elles ont
l'impression qu'ils sont victimes
le système victimiser leur image aux
yeux du peuple
après vingt-cinq ans d'un règne sans
partage hosni moubarak le président
égyptien est aujourd'hui confronté à une
opposition de plus en plus vives
première force de contestation les
mouvements islamistes qui recrutent
essentiellement chez les jeunes il faut
dire qu'aujourd'hui en egypte 60% de la
population a moins de 35 ans aux
pays-bas la justice a condamné à la
prison à perpétuité l'assassin du
réalisateur terry van gogh
le cinéaste a été tué après avoir
réalisé un film critique sur la
condition de la femme musulmane
le meurtrier est un islamiste d'origine
marocaine jusqu'au bout il a revendiqué
son acte devant le tribunal d'amsterdam
et puis ariel sharon vient d'arriver en
france le premier miss heiva lien entame
ce soir une visite officielle de trois
jours la france et israël qui veulent
tourner la page et entamé une nouvelle
relation de confiance après des années
de tension se souvient que l'été dernier
ariel sharon avait appelé les juifs de
france a émigré en israël pour fuir
l'antisémitisme sauvage dans notre pays
aujourd'hui le ton a réellement changé
il parle de progrès d'actions
exemplaires
officiellement le nombre d'actes
antisémites a diminué de 48% par rapport
à l'année dernière et en israël la
population semble elle aussi mieux
disposés à l'égard de la france
regardez ce reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux martin laroche joubert et
mosiah remet ici tous les israéliens
aiment la france il ne s'agit pas de
politique mais de gourmandise
nous sommes dans l'un des meilleurs
restaurants de tel-aviv
les produits sont français
la politique n'a aucune influence sur le
goût nos clients préfèrent les effets
sur la somme à dans les rues les cafés
les opinions sont plus mitigés je pense
que la france est l endroit merveilleux
que j'y ressens en antisémitisme très
fort pas seulement dans la rue au niveau
des autorités
même s'ils disent le contraire j'espère
que la france nous aime mais j'en doute
je souhaite que la visite de sharon soit
fructueuse et que le retrait de la bande
de gaza jouera en notre faveur que tout
ira bien
un sentiment partagé par le plus célèbre
comique d'israël ses sketches à la
télévision sur la france sont grinçant
on voit ici une imitation de jacques
chirac pleurant exagérément la mort de
yasser arafat
les israéliens après si je ne vois
aucune raison nous dit-il qu
sérieusement pour que le gouvernement
français soit aussi pro palestiniens je
sais qu'il ya beaucoup de musulmans en
france et alors la politique doit être
équilibrée quoi qu'il en soit la tension
a baissé depuis la dernière visite de
jacques chirac en 1996 il s'emportait
ici contre les excès de zèle des
services de sécurité
vous voulez que je revienne en france
s'exclame est il de son côté ariel
sharon il ya un an à peine exhorté les
juifs de france a immigré d'urgence en
israël à cause d'un antisémitisme
déchaînés selon lui mais aujourd'hui en
france les incidents anti juifs sont
moins nombreux la presse s'en fait
l'écho
la chute de ces incidents presque le
fait qu'ils ont disparu ç'a changé le
ton des israéliens voient la france
aujourd'hui comme pays amical plus
amicales la preuve la france finance en
partie le futur tramway de jérusalem au
liban après onze ans de prison samir
geagea a été libéré aujourd'hui ce chef
de milice était détenu pour des crimes
commis durant la guerre civile entre 75
et 90 une loi d'aministie votée la
semaine dernière par le parlement lui a
permis de retrouver donc la liberté
il vient de quitter le liban en
direction la france pour l'instant le
quai d'orsay parle de visite privée il
pourrait passer chez l'idée
examens médicaux pour l'instant benoît
16 n'a pas réagi après l'ordination de
quatre femmes au canada
la doctrine de l'église interdit
formellement aux femmes de devenir
prêtre mais ce n'est pas la première
fois en juin dernier une française
avaient déjà été ordonnée lors d'une
cérémonie organisée sur une péniche à
lyon chaque année 2000 français font le
choix de devenir volontaire au sein
d'une organisation humanitaire à
l'étranger soon à mi terrain de guerre
ou aide au développement
il décide de quitter pendant quelques
mois ou quelques années la france pour
venir en aide à ceux qui en ont besoin
le retour est parfois difficile ces
hommes et ces femmes se retrouvent
souvent sans travail sans statut sans
aide
illustration avec ce reportage de
stéphanie davoigneau et jean-christophe
martin un souvenir de ça ils manipulent
avec précaution cette petite gravure en
bois un homme là lui avaient offerte il
ya six mois pour le remercier
c'était après le tsunami c'était au sri
lanka samuel grandjean logisticiens il
gérait une équipe de 100 personnes et un
budget de plusieurs milliers d'euros au
total
il a passé deux années de sa vie en tant
que volontaire aujourd'hui de retour en
france sans emploi fixe
c'est lui qui a besoin d' aide dans les
moments les plus difficiles j'ai dû
aller voir une assistante sociale pour
essayer d'avoir
med alimentaire quand même de réaliser
que ben qu'on a besoin d' aide alors que
jusqu'à présent j'avais tout pour aider
des taux ouais c'est ça peut ça fait mal
au coeur
ni indemnité chômage ni sécurité sociale
pour les anciens volontaires
alors pour l'instant samuel grandjean
accepte les petits boulots en usine
malgré son bts malgré son expérience
difficile à faire valoir auprès des
employeurs doivent se dire deux choses
soit une personne qui part comme ça en
mission humanitaire elle est allumée
c'est à dire un peu folle parce que
c'est un métier dangereux soit
totalement inverse n'est pas productive
parce que elle trop offensif trop
idéologique chaque année l'association
résonances accueille des dizaines
d'anciens volontaires qualifiés mais
sans emploi pour cette responsable des
ressources humaines
les entreprises se feront une fausse
image d humanitaire tarde pas sur le
terrain comme ça avec la fleur au fusil
on part sur le terrain pour des
situations d'urgence des situations de
guerre des situations dans lesquelles il
va falloir gérer un business parce
qu'ils ont un budget qui est
relativement conséquents et on peut pas
confier ça à n'importe qui il voulait
continuer leur vie en france mais
parfois tant de difficultés matérielles
leur donne envie de repartir
l'ancien ministre charles million va
devoir débourser plus de 320 milles
euros à la région rhône alpes le
tribunal administratif de lyon a rendu
sa décision aujourd'hui
la justice estime que charles millon a
bénéficié d' avantages injustifiés
quand il était à la tête du conseil
régional hier nous vous parlions de ses
dix-huit mille kilomètres de routes
nationales qui passe aux mains des
départements c'est une nouvelle charge
pour les conseils généraux qui doivent
déjà gérer le rmi un coût important qui
augmente d'année en année les mettant
parfois dans des situations financières
délicates séverine lebrun yohan mollo
pour pouvoir se servait série
quarantaine de bureaux et 60 perçoit 60
personnes qui travaillaient pour l'état
et qui maintenant sont employés du
conseil général depuis 2004 le rmi est à
la charge du département
ici en seine-saint-denis 48 mille
bénéficiaires 250 millions d'euros a
versé chaque année un budget colossal
que l'état devait compenser dans les
faits ça ne se passe pas comme prévu sur
l'exercice 2004 les compensations qui
ont été versés par l'état sont
inférieurs de l'ordre de 25 millions aux
allocations qui ont été réellement
versés par le département et des
nouvelles charges transférées par l'état
le département en a pratiquement chaque
année
en 2002 c'était l'apa l'allocation
personnalisée d'autonomie
une dizaine de milliers de dossiers
bientôt ce seront 120 km de routes
nationales en piteux état à prendre en
charge sans compter entre autres les
personnels techniques des collèges au
total 300 millions d'euros de charges
supplémentaires en seine-saint-denis
c'est 25% de son budget intenable
pensent qu'ils seront contraints
d'augmenter la fiscalité locale pour
boucler le budget ou alors ou alors
supprimer des activités ce qui est ce
qui n'est pas ce qui n'est pas
concevable à mes yeux
au total ce sont 1,6 milliard d'euros
que l'état devrait transférer aux
collectivités locales d'ici 2008
certains craignent que l'état ne tienne
pas ses promesses malgré ses engagements
désormais tous les transferts de
compétences seront financés à l'euro
près on a tellement voulu rendre cela
clair et net qu'on la constitution
analyser ça veut dire que c'est inscrit
dans le texte le plus important de notre
pays une commission a même été créé pour
évaluer le prix de la décentralisation
elle va tenter de mettre tout le monde
d'accord le gendarme de la bourse la mmf
va ouvrir une enquête sur l'évolution de
l'action du groupe danone l'autorité des
marchés financiers veut vérifier qu'il
n'y a eu aucune transgression du
règlement après des semaines de rumeurs
dopé à de l'américain pepsico le crédit
hors change de mains le célèbre cabaret
parisien été racheté par des
investisseurs belges
les nouveaux propriétaires ont assuré
vouloir conserver l'esprit des revues
qui sont chaîne depuis un demi-siècle
vincent fourcade christophe vignes
elles viennent du monde entier et le
mesure passée d'un mètre 72
tous les soirs de la semaine elle donne
vie au temple français du chic et
raffiné
le crazy horse cabaret parisien mythique
maintenant sous contrôle belge mais
toujours un bon sens et nous devenons
plutôt parisien si vous voulez bien
parce que non seulement nous sommes
bêtes jeu mais auprès de nous nous avons
des banques françaises aidées venture
capitalists français donc c'est nous qui
venons parisien plutôt que l' inverse 54
ans après avoir fondé le crazy horse la
famille bernardin passe donc la main
alors maintenant vous allez droit privé
didier le fils d'alain bernardin
l'inventeur du crazy horse
il n'est plus le patron mais il est
toujours chez lui là où il a grandi
entouré de danseuses au nom unique une
roxy tornado
nous avons une verra nous avons une
psychotique au les trois enfants du
fondateur se donne quelques mois pour
passer en douceur le relais puis ils
partiront l'esprit tranquille certain
que le mythe perdure à la puissance des
idées de mon père est tel que par nature
par force par essence le spectacle
restera c'est très difficile de faire
mieux
c'est très difficile de faire autre
chose mais en même temps il faut évoluer
et l'avenir du crazy horse se jouera en
partie à l'étranger
après las vegas en 2001 le nu à la
française gagnera bientôt l'asie
singapour ou un troisième cabaret
ouvrira dans quelques mois
nouvelles fouilles sous-marines autour
de l'alabama ce navire vous savez
peut-être est un vestige de la guerre de
sécession américaine s'était est un
bateau ultra-sophistiqué pour son époque
l'épave gît par 60 mètres de fond au
large de cherbourg julia delage philippe
turpault pour remonter le temps suivons
le guide 10 20
c'est par 60 mètres de fond que j le
trésor l'un des plus célèbres bateaux de
la guerre de sécession l'alabama
trente ans après sa découverte les
archéologues américains s'arrachent
encore les secrets de cette épave
légendaire c'est le site de la guerre
civile des airs de ces chants qui n'est
pas aux états unis unique au monde fait
partie de votre histoire
au matin de ce 19 juin 1864 le css
alabama est encore le fleuron de la
marine sudiste à voile ou à vapeur c'est
le plus redoutable 70 mètres de long 8
canon en 22 mois il coule près de
soixante dix vaisseaux
il fait halte à cherbourg pour quelques
réparations aussitôt la frégate nordiste
carthage se présente et le provoque tout
simplement en duel à quelques kilomètres
des côtes normandes
après plus d'une heure de combat
l'alabama écoulée 26 marins meurent dans
la bataille
aujourd'hui on trouve encore leur
vaisselle ou leurs cannes en mai à cette
profondeur on ne plonge que 10 minutes
et par sécurité
chaque descente est assisté par des
plongeurs de la marine nationale
française au plus profond sur 30 mètres
donc dans une course dans des conditions
difficiles puisque les froides ya du
courant et les plongeurs effectuent un
travail au fond c'est à dire qu'ils vont
pas juste pour regarder
via le paysage des préfectures travail
pour nous c'est pas gentil opérationnel
mais c'est un bon cadre paul entame en
alabama car serge sudistes contre
nordiste
aujourd'hui les acteurs de cette lutte
fratricide sont réunis pour l'éternité
ils reposent côte à côte face à la
manche
leur dernier champ de bataille après
l'or de manaudou nouvelles médailles
françaises aux championnats du monde de
natation à montréal hugues duboscq a
remporté le bronze sur le 100 m brasse
un bon présage pour les jo-2008
christophe duchiron fradique basile
durant l'été en natation sont à la forme
on défile sur les podiums dans un très
bel ensemble bleu blanc rouge hier à
montréal
hugues duboscq un mètre 91 83 kg pour
parfaitement su ration mannequin il a
terminé 3e du 100 m brasse
l'an dernier à la même époque et à la
même place il était sur le podium des
jeux d'athènes
si dans le monde de la mode on brasse
parfois du vent chez hugues duboscq en
brasse avec talent
pour moi la natation c'est un plaisir
donc j'essaye d'en tirer le maximum de
plaisir voir continuer ce qui fait le
cas aujourd'hui on niveau du plaisir
oui énormément j'ai bien ressenti toutes
les bonnes sensations quand j'ai nagé
j'ai réussi à contrôler ma course
contrairement à d'habitude où j'ai
tendance à ma folle et un peu le premier
50 m dans le deuxième 50 m à la ligne
d'eau numéro 6 en partant du haut de
l'écran
le havrais hugues duboscq a mis tout son
coeur et tout son corps à l ouvrage non
pas pour aller chercher les deux nageurs
devant lui intouchable et pour résister
au retour de l'ukrainien lisogor en une
minute et vingt centièmes et le voilà
troisième au palmarès des championnats
du monde et bronzés pour toute la vie
j'ai fait une course un peu à l'économie
je pense ce que je faisais pas
l'habitude on va dire 30 mètres de
l'arrivée welch qui commence à accélérer
à mettre la tête dans le guidon et ça a
payé
hier soir un peu avant le coucher du
soleil et longtemps après le podium
hugues duboscq a fait des photos avec sa
médaille de bronze et son sourire avec
beaucoup de simplicité et de patience
comme quoi chez le sportif la
décontraction n'est pas un vilain défaut
la preuve ce matin lors des séries du 50
m brasse duboscq s'est qualifié pour les
demi finales en pulvérisant le record de
france les chiffres salle caullet
étudiant en mathématiques et en
informatique dans une piscine ceux qui
brassent du temps
en football à quelques jours de la
reprise du championnat de ligue 1 nous
poursuivons notre état des lieux club
par club ce soir direction auxerre
l'équipe entre deux une nouvelle ère
après 40 ans de bons et loyaux services
guy roux a laissé sa place à jacques
santini roma mais s'ils élisent le nom
andré germain on a beau chercher sur la
photo de famille auxerroises guy roux
n'est pas là et c'est bien jacques
santini l'entraîneur successeur qui est
assis en bout de banc il faut bien s'y
faire après plus de 40 ans de règne dire
ou l'emblème élevé au même rang que
l'abbé deschamps a tourné la page
l' aj auxerre entre dans une nouvelle
ère et c'est toute une ville qui est en
émoi on en parle sur le trottoir on
regrette et on s'inquiète parfois trop
c'est le coeur de la jirs
c'est dommage qu'il soit parti mais
cheyrou je peux lui dire chapeau est par
contre je peux vous dire un truc j'ai
pas confiance à ce rating dire où est
parti mais dire ou es là poursuivis par
les caméras
difficile dans ces conditions d'assumer
la succession jacques santini le nouvel
homme fort balaye la comparaison d'un
revers de main avec le style qu'on lui
connaît
énigmatique la joie est un club
tellement à part qu'on ne peut pas
comparer ce qui n'est pas comparable
qu'on se le dise cependant guy roux
avait peut-être moins d'amis dans son
effectif qu'en centre ville
du côté des joueurs on accueille le
changement d'entraîneur avec
professionnalisme
avec le nouveau coach au bout de trois
jours ça y est j'ai pas qu'on avait
oublié de dire oh mais on était plongé
dans nono nouvelle saison avec un nouvel
entraîneur une nouvelle façon de voir le
football
ces deux méthodes complètement
différente que ce soit dans la manière
de travailler dans la manière de vivre à
l'intérieur
jacques santini a déjà imposé une
méthode avec des entraînements
systématiquement à huit clos et une
équipe mise à l'abri des regards
reste maintenant à voir des résultats
avec un effectif encore en chantier
seul gage d'une popularité futur chara
auxerre on se satisferaient mal d'une
ambition pourtant cher à guy roux le
maintien en ligue 1 on connaissait le
patin roulhac la planche à roulettes et
bien voici la luge à roulettes attention
danger l'activité est plutôt réservé aux
adultes expérimentés yannick à roussety
jean-françois bramard
des virages de la pente une certaine
idée du bonheur pour ces accros du
bitume tout marche comme sur des
roulettes donc d'un blog d'une pièce
trois ex correctionnel doit l'avant
l'arrière
donc on appuie sur cette partie du
baquet pour tourner de ce côté-ci
enseignante irak ou au ping pong ou tout
simplement là il n'y a plus qu'à leur
sceau de pneumatiques sous les semelles
casque et combinatoire c'est parti
quatre kilomètres d'un virage vitesse
moyenne 50 km à l'est au ras du sol 50
mm du sol 100 km/heure quasiment donc ça
va très très vite
c'est génial c'est génial le plein de
sensations sur route fermée
un chassé croisé dans la bonne humeur
entre
la descente est parfaite très bonne
descente et là c'est fun c'est fun les
luges partagent la route avec les skate
les rollers et d'autres engins plus
improbable quand le descendeur et sa
machine ne font plus qu'un il semble que
dans la vie plus il ya de roues plus il
ya plaisir plus calme les festivals de
l'été à pézenas dans l'hérault en
mélange musique peinture et surtout
théâtre puisque aux molières est une
figure de la ville
le tory a vécu pendant trois ans à dalle
mostefa jean-louis melun esprit molière
et tu l'as dans le pays d'un fils
toriques le visiteur d'un soir n'en
doute pas un instant c'est que peu de
temps avant l'arrivée de moyenne a fait
de 9
la grande salle de l'hôtel que j'y vais
comme plein de travaux pour sa visite
guidée il veut de la vieille pierre mais
il vient aussi voir les comédiens bon
dieu me font mourir d'amour mourir me
font vieux le théâtre j'adore l'histoire
donc j'étais comblé parce que bon j'ai
imaginé que j'étais comme un comédien
qui fait la même vie que je vivais dans
les murs et son message génial plus loin
le bourgeois gentilhomme laisse la place
à scapin et ses fourberies oeuvres
célèbres qui est quitte les débuts de
molière raconté dans cette pièce écrite
par georges bégoux les débuts à pézenas
d'un comédien et de sa troupe engagée
par le prince de conti tandis qu'après
plus d'un pièce écrite abordage mauvais
rebond durable
délaisser un peu tristan l'hermite des
corneilles résout ces bouts de vos
interventions vous lire je jouais déjà
il veut beaucoup plus de tragédies ou
des phares ce qu'on dit pas très bien
bâtis dans la pièce est ce le prince de
conti qui ré qui va pousser molière à
l'écriture dans le sud
nos liens oublie farce facile et
tragédie des autres il crée et
s'inspirent les courtisanes qu'il
rencontre de viendront précieuses
ridicules
quant au prince de conti il sera ton
juin voilà c'est la fin de ce journal
merci à vous de m'avoir suivi tout de
suite la météo patrice drevet 20h55 le
cercle rouge avec alain delon 1h05
dernier journal alexandre kara et on se
quitte sur ces images de père noël
même l'été ils travaillent tous les ans
depuis 40 ans plus d'une centaines de
pères et mères noël se rassemblent en
congrès ou d'anna l'occasion de préparer
la prochaine distribution mondiale de
quel dos excellente soirée sur france 2
à demain 20 heures